we're in Portugal with some extreme
sportsmen who are about to repeat a feat
from about 2,000 years ago
[Music]
yes this man is about to walk or run on
water
[Music]
you think they're just gonna sink but
they keep going and it looks like
they're walking on the surface of water
with almost thirteen and a half million
hits so far this uploader inspired many
copycats but are the heroes or hoaxers
we asked Philip and you go the videos
makers we came up with this film called
lincoln mountaineering and it's a hoax
it's fake
we created it yeah it was a viral video
for a sportswear company but could
someone actually run on water these guys
claim that they can do it because
they're running speed is so fast and
it's just like skipping a stone across
water and it's definitely true that if a
human foot or a human hand was to slap
water really hard
you actually feel a reactionary force
the problem is the water pushing upwards
has to counteract the weight of the
human pushing it down the only way you
can do that is by having enormous feet
or running really really fast these guys
aren't succeeding in either of those
consider that Usain Bolt the fastest man
who's ever lived only runs is something
like ten point four meters per second
these guys need to run three times
faster than the fastest man on earth in
order to pull this off
so if it is impossible how did they pull
it off well the trick of running water
the way we filmed it was not done by
computer but it was done for real with a
platform just below the surface of the
water and was a floating platform so if
the he puts the runners put a step on
that platform
it would wobble a bit would move and
that gave us the illusion of actually
stepping on like moving water as opposed
to stepping on a platform and at the end
of the platform as you can see in the
video it just stops they fall in the
water